his name is Murphy he lives at the world
bird sanctuary in Missouri well last
month he went viral when he found a rock
and he tried to hatch IT staff watched
every day as Murphy built a little nest
for the Rock and he protected it while
waiting for the rock to hatch obviously
it's a rock it did not hatch Murphy even
had to be moved to his own enclosure
because it was protecting the rock too
aggressively okay then on April 2nd an
orphaned and Bruce eaglet was bought
into the sanctuary the staff decided to
give Murphy a chance at parenting for
real and what happened folks is simply
incredible Murphy who had never been a
dad before is now an amazing dad staff
at the sanctuary say the two are bonding
beautifully Murphy responds to the
baby's peeps he is protective and he
even waits for the baby to eat video
shows that when the eaglet doesn't eat
right away Murphy takes a little bite
first to show the easy that it's okay